[Musique]
à cette période de campagne électorale à
montréal valérie plantes attaque denis
coderre sur la salle et prix sont encore
très très élevés ont quand même du
double si on compare par exemple à
toronto
est ce que la raison on a vérifié
l'asphalté comme les pommes il y en a
plusieurs variétés
les prix peuvent changer d'une semaine à
l'autre et parfois c'est plus cher dans
un magasin est moins cher dans l'autre
alors ce qu'on vous donne c'est un
aperçu des prix à ce moment ci de
l'année en 2010 on a appelé des
entrepreneurs dans cinq villes qui
vendent des enrobés bitumineux pour le
réseau municipal ce qu'on appelle
souvent de l'asphalté montréal entre 66
et 76 dollars la tonne métrique toronto
entre 71 et 88 winnipeg entre 79 et 99
dollars calgary entre 80 et 110 ottawa
entre 90 et 100 35 quand on parle aux
villes ou spécialistes aux entreprises
tout le monde nous dit que non montréal
ne paie pas plus cher
ce que valérie plantes site ce sont des
chiffres de 2014 et 2015 où on voit que
chaque kilomètre de route à montréal
coûte beaucoup plus cher en entretien
qu'ailleurs mais ces chiffres-là
n'inclut pas seulement le pavage des
roots inclut les nids-de-poule les
fissures les réparations mineures même
le nettoyage des rues à la grandeur de
la ville
il ya deux raisons pour ça d'abord
montréal concède qu'elle est en
rattrapage puisque pendant des années on
n'a pas fait tout ce qu'ils avaient à
faire comme travaux et l'autre chose
c'est que montréal choisi d'amortir ces
paiements sur une moins longue période
que toronto par exemple et quand on fait
quelque chose plus rapidement c'est
normal que les paiements soient plus
élevés si vous voulez qu'on vérifie
quelque chose
écrivez nous
[Musique]